Den Basislaser gibt es umsonst.
Also der kostet so 15, 20 Euro, aber die Bundesregierung hat für 25 Millionen Euro schonmal eine Million angeschafft. Ja, die werden zum Beispiel an die Banken irgendwie verschenkt. Also diejenigen, die die Nüste anbieten wollen, zum Beispiel eine Versicherung oder so, die haben natürlich ein Interesse, das sollte doch benutzen. Überhaupt ist natürlich ein großes Interesse, dass die Bürger das annehmen, da wenn es keiner benutzt, dann haben wir diese ganzen Millionen alle umsonst ausgegeben. Insofern gibt es natürlich so eine Art Incentivierung.
Auch eine Frage, die im Wiki steht, wer verdient denn jetzt eigentlich an diesem neuen Zeug?
Naja, zunächst natürlich erstmal die Leute, die die Lesegräte herstellen, weil jeder, der einen Personalausweis dann so benutzen möchte, braucht ja einen Lesegräte. Aber hier hängt natürlich schon eine fette Industrieförderung dran. Auch die Bundesdruckerei, die ja auch ziemliche Probleme hatte so in letzter Zeit, was ihre Solvenz betrifft. Klar, also hier verdienen eine ganze Menge Leute dran. Es geht natürlich auch um die Chip-Industrie, also hier ist schon eine gute Wirtschaftsförderung am Laufen. Es ist auch nicht so, dass das geheim gehalten wird. Das wird tatsächlich auch als Industrieförderungsprojekt dargestellt. Das ist nicht etwa so, dass das eine Verschwörungstheorie ist. Wir müssen noch ein paar Grüße ausrichten. Wir haben hier so ein paar Langzeit-Meckere. Einer von denen ist Detlef Borchers.
Der hat einen schönen Tweet geschrieben zur Sendung, hab ich gerade gelesen.
Wir müssen ihn mal grüßen und wollen ihn fragen, ob die Schnittchen in der Bundesdruckerei gut geschmeckt haben. Also er wirft uns hier vor, dass wir diese Gleichsetzung zwischen der SuisseID und dem elektronischen Personalausweis nicht vornehmen dürfen, dass es vollkommen unterschiedlich sei. Das tun wir gar nicht. Das tun wir gar nicht. Sondern wir haben nur die sogenannten High-Level-Angriffe halt auf beides, weil sie konzeptuell ähnlich sind, durchführen können. Und deshalb haben wir das überhaupt verglichen. Wir sehen halt diese Angriffe für sehr viele dieser Identitätskarten als gültige Angriffswege. Deswegen finden wir die Kritik eigentlich auch wenig fundiert. Natürlich gibt es da große Unterschiede. Wir haben die auch dargestellt. Aber am Ende konnten wir mit genau den gleichen Angriffstour hier vorgehen. Das ist einfach mal ein Fakt. Also nun ja.
Wenn ihr andere Kritik an der Kritik habt, könnt ihr gerne anrufen unter 0331 70 97 110. So hat es zum Beispiel auch der Max getan. Hallo Max. Du bist jetzt aber nicht der andere Max, der dein Ausweis untersucht hat, oder?
Okay, den würden wir erkennen, der hat nämlich so einen Schweizer Dialekt.
Verstehe, verstehe. Was ist deine Frage zum EPA?
Meine Frage zum EPA ist folgende, und zwar wurde da am Anfang schon mal was gesagt, darauf beziehe ich mich jetzt auch, dass der Ausweis nicht in physikalischer Form vorliegen muss, um ihn auszulesen, beziehungsweise um Betrügereien vorzunehmen. Das würde ich ganz gerne mal genauer wissen, weil an anderer Stelle wird ja genau das Gegenteil behauptet.
Du benutzt schon den Begriff Auslesen, das ist schon mal sehr schwammig, also wir haben nie von Chip Auslesen gesprochen oder von Chip Knacken. Das ist jetzt, ich will dich damit jetzt gar nicht anpaulen, dass das im Endeffekt richtet sich diese Kritik jetzt irgendwie an all diese ganzen Medien und Leute, die jetzt meinen, ihren Arsch retten zu müssen und eben zu sagen, ihr habt ihn doch gar nicht geknackt und ihr könnt ihn gar nicht auslesen. Das haben wir nie behauptet. Wir haben uns nie hingestellt und gesagt, wir können diesen Chip Remote auslesen oder kopieren oder sonst was. Das war überhaupt gar nicht das Ziel unserer Übung.
Ich glaube, es geht max um die Frage, muss man diesen Ausweis irgendwie physisch haben oder nicht?
Und das kann man klar beantworten mit Nein.
Die Antwort ist wirklich klar.
Die Antwort ist Nein. Also ganz einfach, wir wollen den Chip, wenn wir ihn jetzt nicht auslesen, wir wollen im Endeffekt zum Beispiel, also einfaches Beispiel, wir haben eine Banking-Session und machen da eine Überweisung, also irgendeine Transaktion und wir möchten irgendwie diese Transaktion modifizieren, beeinflussen. Aber in irgendeiner Art und Weise, dann brauchen wir keinen Zugriff auf dieses Gerät. Das heißt, es reicht eine Netzwerkverbindung, das ist das, was wir demonstriert haben und dokumentiert haben. Und auch um eine digitale Signatur durchzuführen, also wir haben das bei der SuisseID demonstrieren können, weil wir da halt digital signieren konnten, das sind auch Verfahren, die dann für eine rechtskräftige Unterschrift da verwendet werden können. Da sind wir in der Lage gewesen, remote, also über einen entfernten PC, über das Netzwerk eine digitale Signatur durchzuführen.
Bei der Pin-Änderung von den Auslösen ist das dasselbe.
Genau.
Also wir haben den Pin an einem Ausweis geändert, der an einem ganz anderen Gerät steckte. Wir haben also wirklich tatsächlich damit auch gezeigt, dass man nicht physisch auf diese Karte zugreifen muss, sondern einfach nur den Rechner übernimmt, wo die Karte dran steckt.
Da kommen wir vielleicht direkt zum nächsten Punkt. Da gab es nämlich eine Kritik, aber wenn die den Pin ändern, was haben die denn davon? Wer würde denn so etwas tun? Das merkt doch der Anwender, weil dann geht ja die Pin gar nicht mehr. Was ist denn das für ein Angriff?
Ja, in der Tat. Was ist denn das für ein Angriff? Also ich meine, okay, das ist lustig irgendwie, ich kann dann lachen, weil im Lebenszimmer mein Kumpel seinen EPA nicht mehr verwenden kann, aber ist ja tatsächlich so ein Angriff, wo man so denkt, okay, Schabernagrunne?
Nehmen wir einfach mal an, dass wir irgendwie das Ganze automatisieren können. Das ist ja technisch durchaus machbar. Ja, wir machen das automatisch. Wir nehmen uns irgendeinen aktuellen PDF oder Adobe Flash Exploit, den noch keiner kennt und den kein Virenscanner kennt. Den wir gerade gefunden haben. Den haben wir gerade gefunden. Und dann jagen wir alle Deutschen zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt über irgendeinen Server, wo die auch garantiert rübergehen und dann infizieren wir diese ganzen PC.
Magst du da hier?
Also der Punkt ist hier schon, dass 40 Prozent aller PCs durch diesen Trojaner vielleicht infiziert werden. Und dann ändern wir von 40 Prozent aller Deutschen vielleicht den PIN von dem Pass oder Personals. Die Nile of Service? Ist das eine Option? Ich meine, was machen wohl die Meldeämter denn? Und was machen die Leute? Ich meine, die müssen dann eventuell alle zum Meldeamt rennen und sich einen neuen Perso ausstellen lassen und die müssen dafür bezahlen.
Oder sie rufen alle bei der Sperrhotline an.
Das könnte auch wirtschaftlich, na, wirtschaftliches Interesse.
Aber das ist ja immer eine interessante Frage, also es gibt eine Sperrhotline, das heißt, ich kann sozusagen meinen Ausweis irgendwie, was bedeutet das, den sperren lassen? Der kann dann nicht mehr in der Phone-Teile werden.
Na, wenn man zum Beispiel, das geht ja für ganz normale Fälle, die jetzt nichts irgendwie mit Angriffen per Computer zu tun haben, wenn ich also dem Verlierer etwa oder mir wird meine Börse geklaut, dann gibt es natürlich eine Sperrhotline, so wie das heute natürlich auch gibt. Es gibt ja eine Hotline in diesem Sinne, aber es gibt dann eine Hotline, wo man anrufen kann und sagen kann, ich habe meinen Chip und meinen Ausweis verloren. Und dann ist es natürlich so, dass man den Diensteanbietern zur Kenntnis geben muss. Deswegen gibt es heute diese Hotline. Denn alle, die diese Ausweise benutzen wollen, im Geschäft zu erkehren, müssen natürlich davon an Kenntnis gesetzt werden. Das wird sicherlich ein, zwei Mal am Tag passieren, dass die Datenbanken updaten, welche Personalausweise geklaut sind. Deswegen gibt es jetzt eine Sperrhotline. Wenn man natürlich den Ausweis wieder benutzen möchte, den ein Fremder ja quasi ge-owned hat, indem er die PIN einfach geändert hat, dann muss man zurück aufs Meldeamt. Also das kostet, glaube ich, 5 Euro extra Gebühr. Ich habe die Gebühren jetzt nicht so im Kopf, aber man muss dann eine Gebühr zahlen, auch wenn man es vergisst.
Und warte, die ich bezahle? Ich muss bezahlen, wenn jemand anders meine PIN ändert.
Was ist das Problem damit? Weil hast du nicht gelesen, da steht, der BSI sagt, dein Rechner muss sicher sein. Dein Problem, dein Geld.
Und du unterstützt die Wirtschaft damit.
Ja, ne, dann natürlich gerne. Wir waren bei 150 Euro, 5 Euro für PIN ändern, na gut, da kommt ein bisschen was zusammen.
Ne, ich glaube, ich bin mir bei den 5 Euro nicht sicher, ich glaube, das waren 5 Euro. Es gibt da einige Zusatzgebühren, weil natürlich zum Beispiel aus dem Bereich von den C-Karten bei Banken schon bekannt ist, dass einfach ein gewisser Anteil der Bevölkerung immer wieder seinen PIN vergisst. Das sind natürlich auch Kosten, die entstehen. Das heißt, das kann man vorher ungefähr kalkulieren, wie viel Prozent der Bevölkerung vergessen einfach diese PIN. Das ist ja übrigens auch nicht nur eine PIN. Man muss sich da mehrere PIN... Was? Die kann man sich doch aufschreiben.
Was ist denn die Ausweisung?
Es gibt sogar eine dritte PIN, also man muss sich zwei PIN merken, wenn man auch die Signatur benutzen möchte. Aber es gibt sogar eine dritte PIN, die ist für den hoheitlichen Bereich, die ist aufgedruckt auf dem Ausweis. Wenn man natürlich gegenüber den Polizisten nicht sagen kann, ich sag dir die PIN nicht, deswegen ist die dritte PIN aufgedruckt. Wenn also die Katze, zum Beispiel, naja, da gibt es jetzt viele Modelle, die man sich überlegen könnte, da so eine Ziffer wegkratzt, ist natürlich ein großes Problem. Ihr wisst schon, diese Katzen, ihr kennt das doch, oder?
Ja, ich hab auch ganz viele dieser Katzen zu Hause.
Okay, aber mit der PIN kann man dann sozusagen nur diese hoheitlichen Merkmale auslesen, die sind einfach nur die Dinge, die auf dem Ausweis stehen, plus die Biometrie.
Na ja, richtig, aber natürlich, also jetzt zum Beispiel die Fingerabdrücke sind ja, wenn man die freilich abgibt, die sind ja nicht auf dem Dokument aufgedruckt, also nur auf dem Chip.
Aber sozusagen, da kann man jetzt irgendwie nicht, mit dieser aufgedruckten PIN kann dann nichts irgendwie signiert werden oder sowas, die sind wirklich nur für diese Daten da.
Ja, das ist nur der hoheitliche Bereich, also die Daten, die auch sonst nur von hoheitlichen Stellen abgerufen werden können.
Okay, damit kann man höchsten Polizisten ärgern, wenn die Katze über meinen Ausweis gelaufen ist.
Also falls das passiert.
Also kann man damit ja sicherstellen, dass man wirklich annimmt, dass jemand, der auf diese Daten zugreifen will, diesen Ausweis tatsächlich in der Hand halten muss.
Man braucht die PIN, die aufgedruckt ist, auch für die Signatur, man kann sich also selber an den Fuß schießen, für die Signatur braucht man auch die PIN, die aufgedruckt ist. Aber Signatur wird wahrscheinlich sowieso niemand haben wollen, also wir haben ja schon früher gelernt, elektronische Signaturen werden ja schon länger angeboten, dass das eigentlich niemand haben will.
Da wollen wir nachher auch noch mal technisch ein bisschen ins Detail gehen.
Können wir eigentlich gleich machen, oder?
Erstmal den Max fragen. Du weißt da so ein bisschen.
Oh, war ich Max? Entschuldigung.
Ich hätte vielleicht darauf aufbauen nochmal eine Frage und zwar, wenn eventuell der Personalausweis in der Zukunft die Chance bedient, dass man auch Online-Transaktionen, also Online-Danking damit macht. Bis dato ist es ja so, dass ja viele Millionen Deutsche das Online-Danking wahrnehmen und momentan ist es ja so, dass es da eigentlich ja nur ein bisschen geht. Also ich habe ja meine Tanne zu Hause und mache dann eine Online-Transaktion, aber wenn ich dann das eventuell durch den Personalausweis dann auch machen kann, habe ich ja dann diesen Ausweis und da nochmal zurückzukommen auf die Frage von vorhin in physischer Form bei mir.
Ja, das ist auch das, was die Hersteller natürlich behaupten. Aber wenn du dieses Device, wo dein Crypto-Key da drauf ist, wo du also physikalisch sicherstellen musst, also dass du dieses Ding da hast und in deinen USB-Bus reinsteckst, dass das irgendwie so ein Faktor ist, den du besitzen musst, um so eine Banking-Transaktion zu authentifizieren oder autorisieren, dann, ja, das ist einfach, du steckst das Ding in deinen Computer und dein Computer macht dann irgendwas damit. Das ist also im Endeffekt etwas, was wir bei dieser SuisseID-Technik da zeigen konnten, dass diese Transaktion zwar durchgeführt wird, aber ich zum Beispiel bei einem Man in the Browser Angriff sehr wohl einfach noch Daten manipulieren kann, weil es spielt überhaupt gar keine Rolle, ob diese Smartcard jetzt da ist oder nicht. Man kann sich dagegen effektiver wehren, wenn man einfach noch einen weiteren sicheren Kommunikationskanal hat, zum Beispiel eben so eine TAN-Liste, iTAN-Liste oder imTAN. Das sind eben so mobile TAN-Volumen, dann noch mal eine TAN, die dann dynamisch erzeugt wird und über dein Mobiltelefon verschickt wird, die dann gebunden ist an dieser eine Transaktion. Das erhöht natürlich die Sicherheit enorm, dadurch dass du noch einen weiteren Kommunikationskanal hast. Diese Sicherheit ist auch wieder obsolet, wenn du deine Banking-Session über dein Mobiltelefon abwickelst oder deine SMS auf deinem PC über ein GSM oder Modem erhältst. Die Smartcard bietet da keinen wirklichen Vorteil, kann man nicht so sagen.
Wo wir schon bei den Smartcard sind, ich würde gerne noch etwas nachtragen. Wir haben ja schon gesagt, was das für ein Chip in der SuisseID ist. Ich habe noch mal nachgeguckt, wie die in dem elektronischen Personalausweis sind. Das ist ein NXP Smart MX oder ein Siemens SLE 70. SLE 78. Also wer den Chip wissen will, ich wollte nur mal nachtragen. Ich hatte die vorhin einfach nicht im Kopf weg, wüsste nur, dass die eine NXP ist. Also wer noch mal nachgucken will, ist der Smart MX von der NXP.
Wer den schon mal sozusagen aufbauen will.
Oder der Siemens SLE 78. Es war schon interessant, welcher Chip das wird. Das war auch schon eine Weile quasi für uns eine Frage. Also klar, weil bei uns auch einfach jetzt ein paar Leute sind, die sich sehr intensiv mit dem Aufschleifen und Abbrezen von den Chips befasst haben. Und weil wir mittlerweile auch einen ganz guten Prozess haben, die Bilder, die man daraus generiert, einfach sich ein bisschen automatisiert anzusehen.
Ich möchte noch mal ganz kurz abschließend vielleicht zu der Frage noch was sagen. Wir sind gerade abgewichen. Aber wenn man zum Beispiel auch im Besitz der PIN ist, was wir ja auch demonstriert haben, dann kann man das Ding natürlich auch remote übernehmen und dann damit beliebig Transaktionen durchführen. Also zumindest was die derzeitigen Lösungen angeht, die auf Smartcard basieren. Also wenn ich die PIN besitze und Zugriff auf diese Smartcard habe und ich muss Zugriff nicht lokal haben, das heißt ich kann auch Remote-Zugriff haben. Das ist das, was wir gezeigt haben. Wir haben nichts weiter getan als dieses ganze USB-Device einmal übers Netzwerk zu schieben. Das heißt, auf der Angreiferseite hatte ich Zugriff auf dieses USB-Device, wie als wenn das selber in dem Angreifer-PC drin steckt.
Man wartet halt einen Moment länger, als man üblicherweise kennt.
Das braucht natürlich, aber das ist ein Angreifer.
Das ist schon ein bisschen unbequem, oder?
Aber es funktioniert trotzdem nur so lange, wie verdient das Geld. Wie der Ausweis da auf dem Gerät liegt. Das muss schon sein.
Ja, der muss auf dem Gerät liegen. Man kann ihn ein Stück weg bewegen. Das ist ja eine kontaktlose Technologie, also Funk, aber nicht allzu weit.
Aber wir reden ja auch über die SuisseID und die ist nicht kontaktlos. Und das ist nur so ein Dover-USB-Dongel. Und jetzt muss man sich einfach mal vorstellen, dass der PC in der Regel unter dem Schreibtisch steht und die Leute unter den Schreibtisch krabbeln müssen, um diesen Stick da reinzustecken. Das ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass in solchen Fällen, innerhalb von Sekunden, wo dieser Stick nicht benutzt wird, dann auch rausgezogen wird, damit auch ganz sicher nichts mehr passieren kann.
Es ist schon so, dass in dem White Paper BSI sagt, man möge ihn doch unternehmen, wenn man ihn nicht benutzt. Das ist natürlich auch entlarvend, diese Aussage.
Sie nehmen tatsächlich an, dass eine Angreifersoftware länger als ein paar Sekunden braucht, um dieses Ding zu hijacken oder damit irgendwelche bösen Dinge zu tun. Die Computer sind ganz schön schnell und die Software, die ein Angreifer schreibt, wird auch schnell abgearbeitet. Ich denke, das ist kein Argument, das dauerhaft Bestand haben wird. Ich denke, das sollte ihrem klar sein.
Okay, Max, sind deine Fragen mittlerweile alle beantwortet? Dann viel Spaß mit deinem neuen Personalausweis. So, Thorsten hat jetzt gerade noch etwas erwähnt, was ich zum ersten Mal im Zusammenhang hier gehört habe. Man in the middle kenne ich. Das ist sozusagen, man hängt sich in eine Kommunikationsleitung und tauscht beiden Seiten vor. Man sei der jeweils andere und der richtige und der gute. Jetzt hast du gerade man in the browser gesagt.
Was ist das? Hört sich an wie ein tolles Buzzword aus irgendeiner Media Agentur.
Ich finde, es hört sich an wie ein Flash Spiel. Ist das gut?
Ja, wenn man wie ich viel im Browser arbeitet. Was ist man in the browser? Im Endeffekt haben wir hier die Möglichkeit, Browser beliebig zu erweitern. Das sind dann irgendwie XPIs, das sind Browser-Erweiterungen. Das sind so kleine Module, die kann man sich in den Firefox reinflanschen.
Also grundsätzlich ist man in the browser eine Art und Weise, Rechner anzugreifen. Das habe ich richtig verstanden.
Eine Methode.
Und was du jetzt gesagt hast, diese Erweiterung für Browser ist ja erstmal das, was man kennt. Also was was Gutes ist, ein Plugin, was zusätzliche Funktionalität, wenn man Browser macht. Also dafür gedacht, mit dem Leben einfacher zu machen.
Ja, das ist halt wie ein Programm. Du hast ja ein PC mit einem Betriebssystem drauf. Dann hast du ein PC mit einem Betriebssystem drauf, aber du kannst damit nichts tun, außer ein PC mit einem Betriebssystem zu bieten.
Der Browser kann immerhin browsen, aber gut.
So diese Browser, die haben halt einfach diese Möglichkeit, Module zu installieren, genauso wie du auf deinem PC die Möglichkeit hast, Programme zu installieren. Diese Module im Browser, dass es eben irgendwie mehr oder weniger standardisiert ist, da gibt es halt eine Programmierschnittstelle. Und wenn man sich nach dieser Programmierschnittstelle richtet, kann man da einfach so beliebige Extra-Funktionalitäten implementieren. Es gibt ziemlich viele, die sind sehr sinnvoll. Es gibt halt irgendwie Spielereien. Aber es gibt auch Schadsoftware. Was hindert mich daran, eine Schadsoftware zu basteln, die ich dann im Browser installiere und nicht auf dem Betriebssystem. Also dieses XPI zum Beispiel, das ist dann irgendwie ein Haufen JavaScript. Und ich benutze dann auch ganz reguläre und dokumentierte ARPs, also Programmierschnittstellen. Und naja, nun kann man sich ja mal überlegen, wie wahrscheinlich das ist, dass das von einer Virenssoftware, Anti-Virenssoftware erkannt wird als Schadsoftware.
Aber man hatte noch einen Firewall, sagt das BLSI.
Ja, aber man hat einen Firewall-Block natürlich auch alles, was HTTP ist.
Entschuldigung. Aber wir haben halt schon, also wir mussten schon teilweise schmunzeln über die Hinweise.
Warte, warte, warte. Also zu sagen, es gibt diese Erweiterung für den Browser und da kann man sozusagen, kann man sagen, ihr, kann man auch welche programmieren, die sind sozusagen schadhaft. Also sie spielen dann irgendwas aus, das müssen wir gleich nochmal klären. Aber die kommen jetzt nicht einfach so durchzaubert in den Browser. Also normalerweise werden die Erweiterungen ja von mir installiert. Das heißt, ich müsste den Tonnen noch eine weitere Sicherheitslücke ausnutzen, um das Ding jemand unterzuschieben oder?
Entweder das, also so eine Sicherheitslücke muss natürlich bekannt sein, wenn man die ausnutzen möchte, zumindest dem Angreifer. Die muss ja nicht publik sein, die muss ja nicht öffentlich bekannt sein. Aber ich meine, das einfachste ist, jemandem so ein Ding unterzujubeln. Gerade diese Browser Security ist halt vielleicht manchmal auch nicht ganz so fortgeschritten wie beim Betriebssystem, wo es dann viel mehr Warnmeldungen gibt und so weiter. Aber wenn man einfach sagt, okay, ich nerfe den Benutzer so lange mit irgendwelchen Dialogfeldern, bis er irgendwann Ja klickt, dann hat man es auch. Und dann ist man da irgendwie in diesem Browser drin, kann sich da als XPI registrieren und kann dann meinetwegen einfach im einfachsten Fall ja suchen, ersetzen. Also ich meine, im Endeffekt kann ich auch, ja, ich kann irgendwie gucken, wenn mein Opfer so eine Bankingseite aufruft, dann habe ich die URL, dann sehe ich, ok, jetzt führt er eine Transaktion durch und dann tausche ich ja einfach mal den Betrag und oder die Kontonummer aus und hoffe einfach, dass er das nicht checkt, wenn er dann irgendwie auch noch die Transaktion bestätigen muss.
Also du willst mir gerade sagen, egal wie gut das Lesegerät und die Karte ist, wenn du der Mann im Browser bist, das ist eigentlich egal.
Ja, das hat auch den Vorteil im Gegensatz zu einer Mann in the Middle Attacke, die man halt so netzwerkbasiert kennt, es gibt halt auch keine Zertifikatswarnungen vom Browser.
Naja, gut, also Zertifikatswarnungen sind aber natürlich in der Praxis eigentlich auch nicht relevant.
Nee, aber ich meine, so ein Man in the Browser ist tatsächlich irgendwie so ein Angriffspunkt, wo ich mir sage, das wird ich nicht checken. Weil wie auch, ich werde ja nicht gewarnt. Ich rufe irgendwie meine Webseite auf, wo ich gewohnt bin, dass das Zertifikat immer gleich ist, weil ich das einfach mal auch mal den Fingerprint vielleicht verifiziert habe, irgendwie meine Bank oder was auch immer. Und wenn ich im Browser diese Chartsoftware habe, dann agiert die zwischen dem Bildschirm, also das, was der User liest, und bis zu dem Punkt, wo dann angefangen wird, diese Daten auch zu verschlüsseln und auch zu verifizieren, ob der Server tatsächlich der Server ist. Also ich werde niemals darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass da noch jemand dazwischen sitzt, weil es passiert im Browser.
Das heißt aber auch, dass eigentlich die Angriffe, die wir hier so demonstriert haben jetzt, das gilt in gleicher Weise für die SuisseID wie auch für den Ausweis, dass sie natürlich auch noch stark erweitert werden können, weil diese Männchen so Browser-Angriffe natürlich auch nochmal eine Klasse von Angriffen sind. Und wenn der Mann jetzt Thorsten so sagt, naja, da würde ich mich jetzt mal selber nicht gegen werden können, würde vielleicht sogar mir nicht auffallen, würde mich sehr intensiv mit der Sicherheit meines Rechners befassen. Dann muss man vielleicht auch nochmal nachdenken, dass es hier eben gerade nicht um diese Tech-Community gibt, sondern jeder stellt sich jetzt nochmal kurz seine Mutter oder seinen Onkel vor, der irgendwie auch mit diesem Ding umgehen will. Und da finde ich schon, dass man die ganze Zertifikatssache auch ruhig nochmal betrachten kann.
Ja, das Tolle ist halt, dass wir sie eigentlich gar nicht betrachten müssen, denn wir brauchen gar nicht mit diesem Umstand kämpfen eigentlich. Wir sind überhaupt gar nicht darauf angewiesen, dass ein Benutzer auf unser Zertifikat reinfällt. Er wird es gar nicht merken. Für ihn wird ein valides Zertifikat angezeigt von der Gegenstelle. Und das ist einfach das Tolle daran. Also es ist einfach mal extrem schwer zu bemerken und das ist so.
Und wenn wir jetzt sozusagen eigentlich schon so viele von den verschiedenen Wegen, die A schon gezeigt wurden und B, die aber auch möglich sind, die man durchführen kann, was ist eigentlich die Folge? Also was folgt als Forderung daraus? Also der eine ist natürlich, dass wir erwarten, dass zumindest auf die wichtigsten dieser Sicherheitsprobleme hingewiesen wird bei der Ausgabe. Das finde ich ist einfach eine Forderung, die man an den Staat, der diese gesetzlich vorschreibt, geben muss. Das gilt aber in gleicher Weise aus meiner Sicht für die SuisseID, wo die Unternehmen, die die verschicken, auf sowas hinweisen müssen. Aber wahrscheinlich wird es in der Schweiz sowieso nochmal ein paar signifikantere Folgen geben, als jetzt in Deutschland für den chronischen Personalausweis. Aber die zweite Forderung ist aus meiner Sicht auch, dass bestimmte Arten von Kombinationen, etwa diese billigen Lesegeräte, mit dem Ausweis nicht erlaubt werden sollten. Das ist aus meiner Sicht vollkommen klar. Das ist ein Einfallstor, was man den Leuten unterjubelt. Vor allen Dingen die Leute, die sich nicht mit der Sicherheit ihrer Computer beschäftigen.
Eine berechtigte Kritik an diesen ganzen Verfahren, die wir hier gezeigt haben, ist ja auch gewesen, dass man, man bringt immer Vergleiche. Zum Beispiel sagt man ja auch, man geht ja auch das Risiko ein, überfahren zu werden, wenn man das Haus verlässt und auf die Straße geht und über die Straße läuft. Dann, klar, setzt man sich dann einen gewissen Risiko aus, dass man überfallen wird, dass man überfahren wird und so weiter. Aber wir haben hier bereits in der Grundschule so was wie eine Verkehrserziehung. Das heißt, man wird darauf vorbereitet, man wird als Kind schon darauf sensibilisiert, dass man im Verkehr einfach, im Straßenverkehr vorsichtig sein muss. Und das geschieht hier in Bezug auf diese vermeintliche Erhöhung des Sicherheitsniveaus für so Online-Bezahlverfahren und Authentifizierungsverfahren. Nicht ganz im Gegenteil. Es wird eher suggeriert, dass jetzt alles sicher ist und man eigentlich überhaupt gar nichts mehr machen muss. Der Anwender wägt sich in Sicherheit und das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwie das Fatale an dem gesamten Konzept.
Also da sind wir irgendwie bei der Kompetenz, wo man auch eigentlich immer bei diesem Thema landet. Die andere Frage, bei der man auch immer landet, ist, wenn man so eine Horrorszenarien entwirft, ist sozusagen, wer will das denn eigentlich? Wer interessiert sich denn eigentlich dafür, was ich jetzt mit meinem Ehepaar anstelle? Meine Güte, vielleicht passiert es irgendwann, aber relativ wahrscheinlich auch nicht. Das müssen wir gleich auf jeden Fall auch nochmal klären. Bevor wir das machen, machen wir aber das Fritz-Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr. Und dann geht es hier weiter mit dem Chaosradio.
Superradio 3000, wir spielen die größten Super-Mega-Hits aller Zeiten mit der meisten Abwechslung und den besten von heute im Super-Mega-Mix. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich spiele der Jupp Nippenbräusch von Nippenbräusch Kleiderbügel International Unlimited. Ich habe Millionen mit Kleiderbügel gemacht.
Interessant.
Und jetzt steige ich ganz groß in die Politik ein. Und deswegen werde ich eure Sender-Klitscherer kaufen.
Ich kaufe die Monitorin, ich kaufe die Musiker, ich kaufe die Techniker, der ganze Puff. Und dann kaufe ich mir noch ein paar Radiosender, ohne ein paar Fernsehsender, ohne ein paar Zeitungen dazu. Und alle müssen sich gut über mich berichten.
Interessant.
Und dann lasse ich mich wählen. Jetzt spielt keine Rolle.
Verstehe, da verbinde ich Sie gerne mal eben mit unserer Marketing-Abteilung.
Es muss auch Radio- und Fernsehsender geben, die von mächtigen Milliardären und Meinungsmachern unabhängig sind. Und die man nicht kaufen kann. Fritz?
Es ist ein öffentlich-rechtliches Radioprogramm.
Und abhängig sind wir auch. Aber nur von euch.
Fritz.
Powered bei eurer Rundfunkgebühren.
Und das hört man.
Um kurze halb zwölf.
Fritz-Info.
Nachrichten mit Kai et al.
Die Hochwasserlage in Südbrannenburg bleibt angespannt. Am Abend wurde das Krankenhaus von Esther Werder evakuiert. Vorher wurden 2500 Bewohner der Innenstadt in Sicherheit gebracht. Für den Fluss Schwarzer Elster gilt die höchste Alarmstufe 4. In 16 Schulen der Region fällt morgen die Schule aus. Auch die Nachbarstadt Bad Liebenwerder ist vom Hochwasser bedroht. Dort soll aber zunächst nicht evakuiert werden. Brandenburgs Ministerpräsident Platzek erwartet für morgen eine weitere Verschärfung der Hochwassersituation im Süden Brandenburgs. Bundeskanzlerin Merkel hat die Debatte um steigende Mieten neu angeheizt. In einem Zeitungsinterview sagte sie, dass Hauseigentümer künftig einen größeren Teil der Kosten für Wärmedämmung an die Mieter weitergeben dürfen. Der Deutsche Mieterbund reagierte empört. Es könne nicht sein, dass die energetische Sanierung auf dem Rücken der Mieter ausgetragen werde. Die Europäische Union will Verstöße gegen den Euro-Stabilitätspakt strenger bestrafen. Damit zieht die EU-Kommission Konsequenzen aus der Finanzkrise. Länder, die zu hohe Schulden machen, müssen dann schneller Geldbusen zahlen als bisher. Auch wenn Länder ihre Schulden zu langsam abbauen, müssen sie in Zukunft zahlen. Der amerikanische Regisseur Arthur Penn ist tot. Nur einen Tag nach seinem 88. Geburtstag ist er in New York gestorben. Penn wurde vor allem durch den Film Bonnie und Clyde über das legendäre Gangsterpärchen berühmt. Einen weiteren Erfolg feierte er mit dem kritischen Western Little Big Man. Bei der Berlinale vor drei Jahren wurde Penn mit dem Ehrenbären für sein Lebenswerk ausgezeichnet. In der Fußball-Champions League hat Schalke einen Sieg verbucht. Die Gelsenkirchener gewannen das Heimspiel gegen den portugiesischen Verein Benfica Lissabon mit 2 zu 0. Werder Bremen unterlag im Auswärtsspiel den Titelverteidiger Inter Mailand mit 0 zu 4. In Berlin und Brandenburg sind es aktuell Temperaturen zwischen 7 und 9 Grad. Die Nacht bleibt fast überall trocken und es bleibt auch vergleichsweise kühl bei Tiestärten zwischen 5 und nur einem Grad. Tagsüber lässt sich dann immer wieder die Sonne blicken. Es regnet nur selten und es bleibt vergleichsweise kühl mit Temperaturen zwischen 10 und 13 Grad. Ich habe eine Meldung hier nur aus Brandenburg, A13, Dresden Richtung Berlin zwischen Schönbrunn und Ruhland. Dort ist gesperrt, eine Umleitung ist beschildert. Ihr Grund ist die überflutete Fahrbahn dort. Ihr müsst dort auch mit Staus rechnen. A15 Übergang Forst Richtung Dreieck Spreewald zwischen Cottbus West und Fettschau. Dort liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Drum vorsichtig fahren dort. A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Europien Süd und dem Dreieck Hafelland. Dort fährt ein Schwertransporter, den könnt ihr nicht überholen. Ohne letzte Meldung noch von der B169. Elsterwerder Richtung Cottbus zwischen der Kürzung Plesser und Lochheimer West. Auch dort macht das Hochwasser Probleme. Die Straße ist überspült. Das Ganze dauert noch die ganze Nacht. Dort gibt es auch eine Umleitung. War nicht eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und neue Musik im www.faitz.de be-i-i.
Heute mit Chaosradio, mit Konstanze Kurz und Thorsten Schröder, der hat den EPA auseinander genommen und die SuisseID, das sind beides ähnliche Konzepte zur Online-Identifizierung.
Wir wollten dann nochmal sagen, was genau da eigentlich ähnlich ist.
Aber das haben wir euch schon zweimal geklärt.
Ja, aber offenbar haben noch nicht alle Hörer verstanden. Entschuldigung. Also der Punkt ist, dass das eher ein konzeptioneller Angriff ist, und dass beide Maler einfach durch Schadsoftware einfach an die Daten gelangt werden können. Die mögen physisch unterschiedlich aussehen. Und wer die mal sieht, also einer ist eine Plastikarte, der andere...
Das sind ja sogar andere Chips, die Technik dahinter ist eine andere. Ja, aber hallo, wir haben es gezeigt. Wir haben ein und denselben Angriff gegen beide Geräte gefahren und hatten damit Erfolg.
Exakt den...
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Leute. Es hat kein Hörer, der angerufen hat, bestrungen. Nein, was zur Hölle ist hier gerade los?
Na ja, du musst doch mal sehen, dass wir diesen Chat zur Sendung haben. Nur weil der Moderator bei diesem Chaosradio den nicht mitliest. Es ist schließlich unser vierter Kanal. Na ja, da müssen wir doch uns ein bisschen zu äußern.
Da ist also sozusagen das angeprangert worden, zum Wiederholmal oder wie?
Na ja, weil die so unterschiedlich aussehen, ist vielleicht irgendwie für manchen Hörern immer nicht ganz klar, wie ähnlich sie doch sind, wenn man ganz oben bei den Angriffen ansetzt. Und sich gar nicht weiter mit den Techniken im Einzelnen befasst, sondern sich einfach den Rechner, da wurde im USB eingesteckt, das krallt.
Okay, also man hat jetzt dreimal gesagt, SwissID und EPA sind nicht dasselbe, aber es sind ähnliche Konzepte, deswegen kann man sie auch sozusagen grob zusammen betrachten. Wenn ihr es immer nicht verstanden habt, dann könnt ihr gerne nochmal anrufen, 0331 77 97 21 0 auf weitere Chatbeschwerden. Zum Thema gehen wir jetzt nicht mehr ein.
Richtig.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier tatsächlich noch am Telefon den anderen Max, nämlich den Max, der mit Thorsten zusammen daran gearbeitet.
Hallo Max, grüezi.
Ich rufe an, weil ich noch einen wichtigen Input heute direkt jetzt während der Sendung sogar gelesen habe und zwar hatten wir uns ja die ganze Zeit während den Talks immer und auch während der Vorbereitung überlegt, Mann, das kann ja nicht sein, dass in der Schweiz das zulässig sein kann, dass ich ein JavaScript in einem PDF mitsignieren kann, obwohl es nicht dargestellt wird. Ich habe jetzt das gerade mal durchgelesen und da gibt es tatsächlich einen Punkt zur Nutzung der Signaturprüfung und da heißt es, einen Klarpunkt, die zur Überprüfung der Signatur verwendeten Daten entsprechen den Daten, die der Überprüferin oder dem Überprüfer angezeigt werden. Und ich meine, das ist eigentlich eindeutiger geht es nicht.
Da müssen wir natürlich mal ein bisschen erklären, weil wir sind jetzt nicht so sehr auf die Signatur eingegangen. Vielleicht willst du das mal selber machen?
Ja, ich kann gut zuhören, das ist gar kein Thema.
Vielleicht trennen wir das thematisch, wir haben ja auch noch…
Eine halbe Stunde, also 22 Minuten noch.
Also es ist ja ein Teil von den Angriffen gegen die SuisseID nicht gesendet worden. Dabei geht es zum Beispiel auch darum, dass wir mal schauen wollten, wenn man eine elektronische Signatur mit dieser SuisseID macht, inwieweit kann man da auch den Benutzer täuschen. Das heißt, ist ein PDF, so wie man es angezeigt bekommt, eigentlich das, was man auch elektronisch signiert. Und hier haben wir sehr konkret gezeigt, dass das nicht immer der Fall sein muss. Und darauf spielt Max jetzt gerade an. Denn die unterschiedlichen Applikationen, die PDFs darstellen, die sind halt bei diesem doch sehr umfangreichen Format nicht immer sehr gleich.
Das heißt, die PDF-Spezifikation umfasst mehrere tausend Seiten, wenn man sich auch alle Erweiterungen und so noch mit reinzieht. Und es gibt ziemlich viele PDF-Reader-Hersteller und die interpretieren diese Spezifikation jeweils unterschiedlich, sei es aus Faulheit oder einfach Unwissen. Und das ist ein Punkt, das haben Max und ich auch gezeigt und demonstriert. Wir haben vielleicht ein etwas unglückliches Beispiel gewählt für unsere Demo.
Was habt ihr denn da gemacht?
Na ja, wir haben einen MoFa-Kaufvertrag. Aber vielleicht können wir das einfach nochmal ändern. Wir sagen jetzt einfach mal, wir haben irgendwie…
Jetzt ist gerade der Punkt, wo es so ein bisschen anfängt, die Leute vom Radio zu vergessen, weil die wissen nicht, was ihr mit dem MoFa gemacht habt. Erzählt das kurz und dann machen wir es nochmal anders.
Also, wir haben ein PDF, also wir haben uns die Signatursoftware betrachtet und haben ja gesagt, okay, die ursprüngliche Idee ist ja, dass ich mit einer Signatur sicherstelle, dass ein Dokument nicht mehr verändert werden kann, bis es halt durch den Betrachter nochmal angeschaut wird und halt, wie nennen die das, die Überprüferin bzw. Überprüfer diesen Inhalt auch sehen kann. Das würde ja schon mal als Grundlage benötigen, dass es ein Dokument ist, welches zu Beginn schon nicht verändert dargestellt werden kann, also sprich, keine aktiven Inhalte haben muss. Und da war uns eigentlich schon offensichtlich, naja, PDF ist vielleicht nicht das geeignete Format, genauso wie es vielleicht Wördmarkus nicht unbedingt wären. Und dann hatten wir ganz eine einfache Idee, naja, was ist denn, wenn ich jetzt zwei überlagende Bilder habe und ich mache ganz einfach in einem PDF-Invent, on-page-open, height-picture-2 zum Beispiel. Und somit wird dann das zum Beispiel intakte Webmofa in unserem Beispiel gegen ein anderes ausgetauscht, sofern die Signatursoftware oder der Reader diese JavaScript-Language interpretiert. Und genau da driftet dann die Produkte auseinander, so war es konkret, dass die Signatursoftware JavaScript ignoriert hat, aber das Dokument signiert, also nicht irgendwie darauf hingewiesen oder das nur dargestellt. Und der Acrobat dann zum Beispiel als lesende Funktion hat das sehr wohl interpretiert und zeigt dann das andere Bild an. Dass die Signatur dann noch intakt blieb, das ist nur unter gewissen Umständen korrekt, also man kann das erkennen, dass das nicht der originale Zustand war. Aber der Punkt ist, dass wie gesagt diese Grundlage jetzt gesetzlich mittlerweile anscheinend auch klar ist, dass halt schon das Ursprungsdokument nicht so ist, wie es tatsächlich ist, denn es ist ein JavaScript drin und das wird halt nicht dargestellt. Also mir ist das nicht ersichtlich als Signierer, dass dieses Dokument noch irgendwelche aktive Inhalte hat. Das ist somit natürlich für diesen Gesetzesartikel eigentlich schon Grund genug. Also wenn ich das Dokument nicht alles mir zeigt, was es beinhaltet, ist natürlich die Rechtsgrundlage sehr fragwürdig.
Ok, ich komme jetzt noch aufs konkrete Beispiel zurück. Ihr habt also einen Kaufvertrag gefaked, quasi kann man sagen. Ich unterschreibe den mit meiner elektronischen Unterschrift, sehe darauf ein ganzes Mofa und wenn später irgendjemand anders sozusagen, der den Kaufvertrag begutachtet anguckt, dann sieht ihr da ein kaputtes Mofa und oder wie?
Genau, und die Signatur blieb in diesen Beispiel, wie gesagt, das kann man erkennen, aber das ging es mehr darum, dass es tatsächlich Unterschiede gibt in der Darstellung und das ist natürlich entgegen jeder Idee von einer Signatur mit Unveränderbarkeit.
Es hätte keinen Bestand, wenn da ein Richter oder ein Forensiker noch mal draufschaut, wenn es später zu einem Rechtschreib kommt. Das ist völlig richtig, aber deswegen möchte ich eigentlich gerne ein anderes Beispiel reinbringen. Zum Beispiel, ich nehme einen Arbeitnehmer, der bewirbt sich in einer Firma, wo er seit zehn Jahren arbeiten möchte, sein Wunscharbeitgeber und er schafft es endlich da reinzukommen und der macht mutwillig eben so einen Trick mit irgendeinem dynamischen Inhalt in so einem PDF und dann schließen die einen Arbeitsvertrag und irgendwann, nachdem auch der Arbeitnehmer das ganze Ding unterschrieben hat, stellt er fest, wieso habe ich jetzt nur noch die Hälfte Urlaub. Also einfach so ganz banale Sachen, wo der Arbeitgeber definitiv profitiert und auch mutwillig beschissen hat, da wird wohl nicht die erste Tätigkeit des neuen Arbeitnehmers sein, vor das Arbeitsgericht zu ziehen und diesen Vertrag anzufechten, weil er irgendwelche dynamischen Inhalte hat.
Es ist natürlich, das Format an sich ist natürlich eben sehr umfänglich.
Ja, das ist überhaupt nicht dafür geeignet. Also gar nicht.
Eigentlich müsste man sagen, dass die Signatur nur für so einfache Formate wie zum Beispiel Plain Text, also einfacher Text überhaupt ermöglicht werden sollte und diese dynamischen Inhalte, wo man ja die volle Mächtigkeit einer Programmiersprache hat, die sollten eigentlich so nicht drin sein.
Posttrip, das ist eine mächtige Programmiersprache im Endeffekt.
Ich bin sogar der Meinung, und das ist eigentlich, also wenn ich jetzt diesen Artikel hier wirklich durchgelesen habe, ist schon die Frage, ob solche Sachen wie Exif-Tags in Shape-Tags oder was auch immer, die mir nicht dargestellt werden in diesem Dokument, nur schon dem genüge tun. Also sprich, nur weil es jetzt kein PDF ist, heißt es ja nicht, dass es alle Daten, die existieren in dem Dokument, wie er auch wirklich dargestellt werden. Schon noch eine interessante Diskussion bei der ganzen Sache. Ich habe da mittlerweile auch gelernt, dass dieses Beispiel mit dem Moorverkauf, das hängt vielleicht an Enten und Unkanten, aber man darf nicht vergessen, wenn die Gegenstelle ein Automatismus ist, also nicht ein Mensch-Mensch-Bezugung, sondern irgendein E-Government-Dokument, welches automatisch verarbeitet wird. Wenn die Gegenstelle zum Beispiel jetzt diese Sachen rendern würde, auch wenn es sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, dann hat das unter Umstand zur Folge, dass die Maschine etwas anders interpretiert hat als tatsächlich in diesem Dokument stand.
Das ist sogar gar nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich, das habe ich auch im normalen Leben schon häufiger erlebt, das kommt halt vor.
Ja, sprich Dokument-Parser können auch nicht so gut sein, im Endeffekt. Das wollte ich nur noch mit einbringen, dass da tatsächlich noch eine kleine Änderung stattfand. Sprich, diesen Artikel gibt es, der ist einfach sehr offen gehalten, aber zeigt eigentlich, dass so eine Software, wie sie jetzt das handhabt, dem nicht genügend zählen kann, also definitiv nicht.
Okay, jetzt haben wir also sagen noch etwas weiteres gelernt, das ist nicht nur sagen, mit der Identifikation schwierig, sondern auch mit der Signatur kann man schön viel Unfug treiben. Scusi ist außerdem noch am Apparat und möchte noch ein paar Horror-Szenarien beisteuern.
Oh ja, Horror-Szenarien.
Guten Abend, ich wünsche euch noch einen schönen Rest, ich höre noch zu, ich glaube, dann ist die Leitung da auch wieder frei.
Wir können da doch zu viert und zu fünft hier. Diese Schweizer mögen uns nicht. Bleibt ruhig noch da, wenn ihr möchtet.
Hallo Max, hallo Konz, hallo T. Also mir sind noch ein paar lustige Sachen eingefallen von vorhin, dass mit der alte, mit der DOS-Attacke, gegen möglichst viele Ausweise, Pin-Nummern, Länder und so. Na ja, das kann man ja noch erweitern zu einem richtig lukrativen Cybercrime-Geschäft. Also ich meine, ein neuer EPA kostet 28 Euro und man muss zum Einwohnermeldeamt, wo selber, wenn der Angreifer die PIN für 15 Euro frei Haus per E-Mail schickt, dann wäre das ja vielleicht ein interessantes Geschäftsmodell.
Wir könnten alle reich werden.
Ja, aber guck mal, das ist doch ethisch fragwürdig, oder, Susi?
Das ist ethisch fragwürdig, aber ich meine, wir hatten es ja vorhin auch von Industrieförderung und zu befürchten steht halt einfach, dass das wirklich eine Industrieförderung ist. Allerdings wird der größte Nutzen nie so wohlmöglich die Cybercrime-Industrie.
Ja, das ist ja auch die Befürchtung, dass tatsächlich auch mal jemand in kurzer Zeit zeigen kann, dass man auf größerer Basis einfach schaffen kann. Das ist natürlich schon auch eine Gefahr aus meiner Sicht. Aber da ich eigentlich annehme, dass auch nur ein sehr kleiner Anteil der Bevölkerung überhaupt diese elektronische ID nehmen wird, also das wirklich benutzen wird, zumal am Anfang. Und noch viel schlimmer bei der Signatur ist es wahrscheinlich eher noch Zukunftsmusik.
Aber eins muss man auch noch mal ganz klar sagen, was diesen elektronischen Personalausweis angeht und all diese Möglichkeiten, die man hat als User und auch als Betrüger, auf beiden Seiten sinkt die Hemmschwelle damit irgendwie Unfug zu treiben. Also Angreifer brauchen eben nicht mehr hinter der Ecke nachzulauen, dass jemand vorbei rennt und ihn mit dem Knüppel über den Kopf hauen, um den Ausweis zu stehlen. Man kann übers Internet agieren, aus anderen Ländern, man kann seine Spuren verschleiern. Die Hemmschwelle sinkt. Ob man sich dabei dämlich anstellt und da ertappt wird oder nicht, ist mal dahingestellt.
Aber ich muss jetzt an dieser Stelle schon mal fragen, also alles was ihr sagt, was ihr jetzt sagen, über die Sicherheit dieses e-Pounder, CCC, die sagt, das könnte man ja theoretisch auch anwenden auf Online-Banking. Das sind jetzt ziemlich viele Horror-Szenarien, was aber andererseits bedeutet, eigentlich wäre doch heutzutage schon die totale Katastrophe möglich mit Online-Banking? Warum ist das nicht der Fall?
Na ja, wir hatten das vorhin schon mal kurz, als Thorsten erklärt hat, dass sich natürlich die Banken etwa mit diesem zweiten Weg, dass man eben auf seinem Mobiltelefon noch einen TAN hat oder schriftlich zu Hause einen TAN, auch schon Möglichkeiten überlegt haben, dem entgegenzusteuern.
Naja, aber da gibt es ja dann die Man in the Browser-Attacke, die auch das wieder aushebelt, dann können wir auch wieder sagen, okay.
Also man darf hier nicht, ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen Äpfel mit Birn vergleichen, weil man muss ja sehen, in einem Bankenumfeld existieren ja nicht nur die technischen Maßnahmen, sondern man hat ja typischerweise über Jahre hat man im Prinzip ja Profile angelegt, welche begünstigten sind populär, welche Zahlungsverhalten hat der Herr Moser zum Beispiel gegenüber seinen, wie hoch sind meine durchschnittlichen Beträge der Zahlung und so weiter. Und solche Fortdetection-Mechanismen sind ja ganz unabhängig von den Techniken. Und somit ist natürlich der Missbrauch. Ich würde jetzt auch mal einfach so behaupten, dass die meisten Detection von Phishing-Sachen eher auf dieses zurückzuführen, sondern auf technischen Mitteln. Und das ist natürlich ganz etwas anderes, wenn wir jetzt davon sprechen, dass Hinz & Kunz ein Web-Shop öffnet und das mit dieser Authentifizierung ja total sicher ist, weil die Applikation ist ja jetzt auch sicher, weil ja jetzt noch die Person identifiziert wird. Das ist nicht zu vergleichen.
Ich bin mir aber noch nicht ganz überzeugt, weil das, was du jetzt sagst, könnte man auch sagen, bei Banking halt nicht, dann aber meinetwegen bei Kreditkarten. Da kann ja auch jeder Web-Shop-Betreiber herkommen, ist das viel Geld, wo muss man da irgendwie bezahlen?
Na auch da ist eine Lösung gefunden worden, die noch gar nicht so lange her ist, nämlich die sogenannte, diese Sicherheitsnummer, die auf dem Dokument aufgedruckt ist, die man zusätzlich jetzt ja eingibt und die darf ja zum Beispiel der Anbieter auch nicht speichern. Aber auch hier ist es so, dass natürlich trotzdem eine Menge Schadensfälle bei den Banken auflaufen, weswegen sich bei den Banken jetzt ja auch was ändert. In der Zeit wird in Deutschland das sogenannte PIN-and-Chip-Verfahren, bei Visa heißt es Verified, bei Visa und bei Mastercard heißt es Secure Code, ausgeräutet, heißt wir erhalten jetzt gerade in Deutschland alle Kreditkarten, die einen Chip enthalten und man muss jetzt sich da auch eine PIN merken. Und hier ist ein sehr ähnlicher Effekt zu beobachten, wie wir beim Personalausweis haben, nämlich, dass die Problematik der Sicherheit mehr und mehr auf die Kunden ausgelagert wird und beim EPA auf die Bürger und bei der SuisseID eben diejenigen, die die kaufen. Das heißt, man muss sich selber darum kümmern, dass wie man nutzt, sicher ist. Denn auch bei diesen PIN und Chip-Perferen, bei den Kreditkarten gibt es Angriffswege, die sind auch bekannt, so wie es jetzt bekannte Angriffswege für die SuisseID und den Ausweis gibt. Aber die Defensline ist da irgendwie immer, ja, da müssen sich die User eben darum kümmern. Und das ist natürlich immer umso schlimmer, je hoheitlicher dieses Dokument ist, weil hier ist ja der Ausweis schlicht gesetzlich vorgeschrieben und bei der SuisseID hat das natürlich auch hoheitliche Elemente, auch wenn das jetzt drei Privatunternehmen sind, weil das ZECO, der Schweizer, ist beim Wirtschaftsministerium oder, Max?
Keine Ahnung, ZECO ist ein Interesse-Ningstherum für Wirtschaftsförderung.
Genau, also so ganz weit weg ist es auch nicht, auch wenn es natürlich keine gesetzliche Pflicht gibt. Im Übrigen, in Deutschland, also beim elektronischen Personalausweis, ist die Signatur auch überhaupt nicht hoheitlich. Das ist sozusagen, was sich der Bürger dazu holt, insofern sind die Unterschiede wiederum gar nicht so groß. Aber ich habe so den Eindruck, dass du den Trend hast, dass man Sicherheitsrisiken auf den Benutzer abwälzt und auf die ganzen Haftungsfragen damit ändert.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall ein Trend und man kann, also was noch gar nicht beleuchtet wurde, ist, dass dieser neue Ausweis ja auch für andere Dinge als für die hoheitliche Ausweisfunktion benutzt werden soll, zum Beispiel für Altersverifikationen im Internet. Und da ergeben sich natürlich interessante Angriffsvektoren, also wenn Cyberkriminelle anfangen, Webseiten die Altersverifikationen über diesen neuen Ausweis anbieten, anzugreifen, dann entstehen da natürlich Möglichkeiten, gezielt Leute mit Ausweisen anzugreifen, die den eben zur Altersverifikation nutzen. Und dann bin ich mal gespannt, ob nicht durch Social Engineering, so von wegen, nein, nicht die PIN, sie müssen die andere PIN eingeben, nicht auch Zugriffe auf ganz andere Bereiche des Ausweises möglich werden.
Das ist eine interessante Kombination aus technischem und sozialem Hack, hmmm.
Na das wird doch passieren. Also ich meine, das sieht man ja auch im Bankenumfeld und so. Genau solche Sachen werden ja passieren.
Ja, also das finde ich nicht unrealistisch. Das ist natürlich eine große Gefahr, weil der hoheitliche Bereich ja normalerweise überhaupt nicht für die Wirtschaft irgendwie zugänglich sein soll. Überhaupt nicht. Eigentlich hätte es nur, wenn man sich gegenüber den Behörden ausweisen soll.
Ja, deswegen gibt es ja da auch eine andere PIN, soweit ich weiß.
Nein, das ist die, die aufgedruckt ist. Sie ist sechsstellig und ist aufgedruckt auf der Plastikkarte.
Da sind wir auch schon bei meiner nächsten Frage, nämlich kann man die Daten, die hoheitlichen Daten, also das Lichtbild und wohlmöglich Fingerabdrücke und Name, Anschrift und so weiter, mittlerweile denn auslesen von diesem neuen EPA? Beim Reisepass ging das ja immer ziemlich einfach mit dieser Basic Access Control, die da drauf war. Bei dem neuen Ausweis ist das ja ein bisschen schwieriger.
Das ist richtig. Musst du mal genauer wissen, was willst du denn auslesen aus dem?
Na, so die Passinhaberdaten, also Name und Geburtsdatum und solche Sachen.
Nein, das kann man nicht selbst auslesen, man kann aber soweit ich weiß, wenn der ausgegeben wird, aufs Meldeamt gehen und sich das zeigen lassen, was auf dem hoheitlichen Bereich drauf ist. Das kann ich auch heute mit dem Reisepass. Das ist nicht für den Bürger gedacht, der hat mit dem hoheitlichen Bereich gar nichts zu tun und kann es auch nicht auslesen.
So, jetzt sind wir bald schon wieder am Ende der Sendung und wie immer bei diesen neuen Technologien entsteht der Eindruck, okay, es gibt also viel daran auszusetzen, man könnte vieles besser machen, aber sie werden ja auf jeden Fall kommen. Oder seht ihr irgendwie eine Chance, dass da noch was verhindert wird? Oder wollt ihr das überhaupt verhindern?
Man muss sehen, was hinter diesem Projekt ist, von den Idealen her steht. Ich glaube, das ist bei der SuisseID schon wieder nicht so sehr anders als beim IPA. Dann geht es um schlichte Wirtschaftsförderung. Würdest du das anders sehen für die Schweiz, Max?
Nein, der Punkt ist einfach, wir sagen da immer ganz gerne bei Diskussionen einfach, so wie wir die Zukunft irgendwie malen können, dass die anderen auch und es sind noch viel zu wenige Applikationen und tatsächliche Use-Cases, die funktionieren, vorhanden, obwohl ja schon bereits 10.000 draußen sind. Und bis Ende Jahr waren es ja glaube ich über 100.000 oder so sein, aber ich sage es mal, 10.000 war die letzte Zahl, die öffentlich war und Applikationen gibt es noch fast keine. Also wie die Zukunft aussieht, das ist ziemlich Kristallkugel für alle Involvierten.
Was ist denn jetzt eure Empfehlung für die deutschen, neuartigen Rundfunk-Empfangsgeräte-Benutzer? Was sollen die jetzt machen?
Also das eine ist, es ist durchaus der Preis zu zahlen. Die knapp 30 Euro müssen auf den Tisch gelegt werden, aber man kann sich ja entscheiden, ob man das für die Signatur vorbereiten will und ob man die elektronische Identitätsfunktion benutzen will. Wir raten jedem, das nicht zu tun, darüber hinaus empfehlen wir die Deaktivierung des Chips.
Gibt es da eine offizielle Stelle?
Das darf man natürlich eigentlich nicht, aber das kann ja mal passieren, wenn man den Chip da zum Beispiel überlegt und er dann nicht mehr funkt. Wir empfehlen das durchaus, weil das ist ja auch eine Sicherheitslücke, die man durchaus mal betrachten muss. Das nehme ich, wenn ich in der U-Bahn sitze, vielleicht der, der neben mir sitzt, nicht wissen soll, dass ich einen funkenden Personalausweis bei mir trage, auch wenn er nicht wissen kann, wer ich bin und wie ich heiße. Aber er kann sehen, neben mir sitzt ein Personalausweis und das wäre mir persönlich auch nicht recht. Man kann ihn also entweder in so eine Metallhülle packen oder aber den Chip deaktivieren, das schadet ja auch nicht. Na, da gibt es die sogenannten RFID-Zapper. Wir haben die ja neulich auch, da hat der WDR neben der Tatsache, dass er den Hack mal ein bisschen gezeigt hat und wie man eigentlich das wirklich macht, also die Demonstration der Sicherheitslücke, hat da auch mal eine, glaube ich, achte oder neunte Klasse eines Gymnasiums besucht und hat so einen RFID-Zapper bauen lassen aus einer Einwegkamera und dafür haben wir auch eine Anleitung im Netz und die haben, die Kids in der Schule haben das ziemlich gut gemacht, erfolgreich, haben den durchgeführt. Wir haben so was ja selbst schon mal gemacht mit so Workshops für Schüler. Wir haben also eine Bauanleitung, wie man aus einer normalen Einwegkamera so einen RFID-Zapper baut. Wir empfehlen aber, die nicht in der Nähe von Menschen mit Herzschrittmachern zu benutzen.
Okay, also lieber vielleicht doch einen ganz alten, heißt es eigentlich APA? A la Loga Personalausweis, das alte Gerät, was wir noch irgendwie wissen.
Der neue heißt jeweils TPA, für teurer Personalausweis.
Okay, also die Sendung ist jetzt gleich vorbei. Wo kann man sich belesen, wenn man noch weiter tiefer und mehr ins Thema einsteigen will?
Also wir haben eine sehr umfängliche Pressemitteilung gemacht, die auch zu empfehlen ist in Bezug auf die weiterführenden Links, weil wir da noch weitere Hinweise geben, haben wir da auch noch mal die ganzen Sachen, die Thorsten und Max in ihrem Vortrag ausgeführt haben, noch mal verlinkt sind, aber auch noch darüber hinausgehenden Links. Wir haben zu der ganzen Frage der Biometrie und der Elektronifizierung von Ausweisdokumenten natürlich schon öfter mal gesprochen und wir empfehlen den Besuch des 27. Chaos Communication Congress. Das ist zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, wenn wir uns natürlich diesem Thema auch wieder widmen.
Gibt es da schon Karten? Was? Gibt es da schon Karten?
Der Kartenvorverkauf wurde leider wegen, ähm, wegen, ähm, ähm, Aber der Kongress findet statt. Der Kongress findet statt, aber der Vorverkauf hat sich so ein bisschen verzögert, denn wir werden ja diesmal ausschließlich vier Tageskarten im Vorverkauf haben.
Chaosradio 161 über den elektronischen Personalausweis von Swiss ID. Vielen Dank, Thorsten Schröder und Konstant zu kurz, die hier zu Besuch waren. Vielen Dank auch den Anrufern und Mitmachern und mit Wiki-Schreibern und mitchattern. Wir sind jetzt hier gleich raus, geben ab an, es müssen Smart im Night Flight Nummer 123. Da gibt es immer auf Facebook so eine schöne Meldung, was passiert. Ich vermute, also ich vermute nur, der Herr Smart hat mir da heute tatsächlich so eine Art Rap hingeschrieben, aber ich glaube, ich krieg's nicht hin, deswegen versuche ich's. Also den ersten Satz vielleicht. Auf Rap, Dubstep, ob langsam oder schneller, von pervers bis prima, liegt heute auf dem platten Teller. Ich glaube, ich erspreche euch den Rest. Ich kann nur sagen, die Holzfäller kommen vorbei, bleibt die nächsten drei Stunden auch noch dran. Ich bin raus, sage tschüss und natürlich geht auch der letzte Ruf raus. Macht immer schön eure Backups und lasst euch nicht überwachen. Jetzt aber raus jetzt.